we got a lot to cover today No hi my
name is Grace help you did not know now
you know your life is different now this
is a favorites video and it's not just a
favorites video it's a favorites video
I've been done a favorites video in a
little bit but I have been living thus
I've been using things and I enjoy some
things more than I enjoy other things
and I feel like the Internet is a place
to share that knowledge that information
that passion and then nudes
I got hair stuff to talk about makeup
stuff to talk about clothing stuff to
talk about home stuff to talk about
health stuff to talk about there should
be something for everyone in care and if
there is it well you can see directly
off kindly oh I don't even know where to
start sir the face the sort of the
moneymaker
literally let's build a solid foundation
of service some foundation me yes
petting I'll say hey I see ease to that
there's gonna be a lot of that cuz
they're so there's a lot the cover
didn't scum
because you know I try to keep things
nice and I just can't if there are
spiders on me in this video I'm just you
know it's part of my brand now these are
to higher-end foundations usually I buy
drugstore foundations that I use on a
regular basis but these two are two that
I've invested in because sometimes when
I'm really sad I wake up and I buy
myself
mmm slightly expensive things in an
effort to make myself feel better they
call that retail therapy buying your
happiness unlike real therapy when it's
done you end up with things treasures
this is Charlotte Tilbury airbrush
flawless foundation I've never bought a
Charlotte Tilbury thing before because I
didn't think I was like British enough
but I did and guess what the website
took my credit card I'm in I hacked into
the mainframe and I like it one because
it's a classy bottle so by proxy makes
me feel very sophisticated too it's
really lightweight but gives me high
coverage which is what I enjoy most I
build up invisible emotional walls and I
like to pack on visible foundational
walls this had a lot of great ratings on
two floors website the one tiny issue is
that I hate going to stores to try and
color match or to try and interact with
someone that could color match me so I
always guess this is a
little off for me if you think hard
enough that it's not then you're good
it's just very pretty it's got a rose
gold top-up look at me being beautiful
it has a pump which I like I don't have
to do any pouring any weird like dropper
system thing that stuff you this I've
talked about in favourites videos in the
past and guess what it's still a
favorite that's how much I like it it's
Make Up For Ever Ultra HD foundation
real high coverage I like cake for
breakfast and I like cake on the face
and this really does it for me not
exactly the right color for me but when
I mix it and I put other [ __ ] on it it
really works out pump system love it
these are the high-end foundations that
I've been really into lately cute next
yeah this is a tinted moisturizer in
case I ever want to just wear tinted
moisturizer this is the one I would go
to but I don't do that instead sometimes
I use this tinted moisturizer as a base
before I put on my foundation because
that's how crazy I am about covering
everything this is Laura Mercier tinted
moisturizer in the color porcelain it's
easy to travel with and this is what I
use like I said as my base or primer
before I put on foundation and it works
I don't know what else to say about it
if you're new here you'll learn quickly
that I'm not the most educated and most
of the things but I have an excitement
for things that seemingly work for me
this was purchased in the whole buy it
and you'll feel happy purchase that I
did not so long ago so look like I have
it look how happy I am nothing's wrong
Jude next yes I'll say yes like this is
born this way multi-use sculpting a
concealer I use this for my under eyes
and it really gets the job done it's
almost like that men in black pen that
erases your brain but this erases all of
the stress and inability to sleep marks
that form under your eyes like this in a
travel sized version because that's how
I show restraint oh what a fun noise
come on let me have it
got a thick coverage but it doesn't feel
too greasy I've been using this like
crazy and there's still a ton left so I
feel like I really got a lot of bang for
my buck
speaking of bang
next these hey yeah say yeah yeah say
yeah I'll say it please are covered in
scum these are from GG gorgeous makeup
collection Thank You Gigi she actually
set these to me this is the only blush
duo about authentic and pride look at
that so goddamn gorgeous there's a
shimmery blush on this side and a more
matte blush on this side it makes me
feel very feminine I have them on my
cheeks right now and I really really
enjoy it it's called the only blush duo
and to be very honest it is the only
blush duo that I have been using this is
the only throw pool that I want to be in
right now and then this is turnt
touch-up powder it's just setting powder
I'm so bad at owning setting powder at
let alone using it I've been using this
like crazy and I love it and it's just
package really pretty also Elliott's
even use this for a shoot recently and
it worked really well it's like got this
matte packaging that's really nice to
kind of do this with you neck thing is I
think I've talked about this in the past
but guess what it's back her brow
benefit eyebrow stuff gel brow smash it
into your eyebrows and then they become
you know eye brows this thing comes off
and it's a brush when you turn it around
and you put it back on that cap undo
this dip dip dip brows brows brows
suddenly huh I could be shocked I could
be surprised those are the same and my
face is a work of art because it's been
put in a frame I got a little bit darker
than I probably needed this is in the
color 3 it's for when I want to be very
serious professional businesswoman
it makes my eyebrows look like sharp and
pointed sometimes so it's like impress
me okay look at those eyebrows well but
also because it's a brow gel it stays
all day and sometimes I get a little
crazy hairs that like to be individuals
this just puts them all in a row puts
them all in place it's like putting a
leash on a child you next can't say yeah
say yeah this just looks very curious
looks like a very chic vibrator it's not
mascara steel --is huge is that what
it's called just steal this huge extreme
lash mascara I think it was like mmm 20
bucks or something maybe but I love this
it's so wet clumps but in the good way I
can use just one layer of this and it's
just it's it looks like
speaking of spiders spiders on my
eyelashes and that's the only place I
want spiders on my body or just cute
yeah yeah can you say yeah yeah like
this is fenty beauty Rihanna's makeup
line I've never bought anything from
Fenty Beauty before and I bought this
it's called Shady Bizkit sassy sun
stalker instant bronzer and I got the
travel size because again I thought that
that was me being frugal one the
packaging very beautiful it was the
illusion that I'm a girl that you know
cares when you open it oh so pretty it's
perfectly sized to travel with I like it
very much the packaging makes me feel
fancy and spoiled and the bronzer itself
I love it look at these cheekbones Wow
it's cereal out of these two hollows of
my face right now all thanks to this and
I guess genetics too but you can't buy
that at Sephora could you imagine yeah
next yeah and you'll say yes say yes to
face hangover three-in-one replenishing
primer and setting spray I got this
let's be honest because the name is fun
hangover cure yeah you got me I think of
prime my body to have the feeling of a
hangover in my natural resting state
it's a true treat I spray this on my
face before I put other things on my
favorite nose if it's actually just a
fancy bottle of water that I'm spraying
but a placebo effect is great it's
lightweight it doesn't smell weird and
it sits on my face real nice everything
you want in a partner
yeah that's a bunch of hair I have a
relatively shoddy hombre situation going
on because I haven't been to get my hair
cut or colored for like two months
that's on me when I want to maintain my
blonde this is what I go for yeah say
yeah yeah say is a Mondale brightening
shampoo from Drybar I like all of the
products that Drybar makes I'm a sucker
for branding and packaging this is a
brightening shampoo it's a purple
shampoo for blondes I like it a lot it
doesn't
make my hair to dry it out so ya wash
with it this morning it's like when you
throw water on a sleeping person and
they like
wake up that's what I feel like I did to
my hair this morning with this shampoo
it takes out the brassy tones my hair
doesn't look like a trumpet anymore
you'll say you hang up see and you'll
see it this is from kandi Johnson's new
hair product line it's mermaid moisture
from pop lamps and ultra hydrating hair
mask and I love this I'm about halfway
through this and it just lo it smells so
good I was like what you imagine candy
Johnson smells like like if she used
cotton candy as deodorant like this yeah
that's what this smells like I use this
when I travel because I very
infrequently as you know wash my hair
but when I do I try to put some kind of
conditioning hydrating mask on it to
make up for all of the previous laziness
she also has shampoo and conditioner and
they all smell the same they all smell
like this highly recommend you yes yeah
yes so yes like this is dry shampoo
every gummy girl's best friend is some
dry shampoo and this is wonderful this
is batiste instant hair refresh dry
shampoo plus because it's for blonde you
can get away with not read eyeing your
roots for weeks and months if you use
this at least that's what I've done it's
dry shampoo but it adds a little little
subtle bit of color just oh I look smart
shake it in a little bit look you can
barely tell the difference but I can and
that's all that matters I wear beanies
all the time just because once I put
them on my head and they make me feel
safe and they make my head feel warm I
never want to take them off but what
they do is they keep it on my scum and
they just marinate it a little bit so my
roots tend to look greasy pretty
frequently and this really helps counter
that yeah yeah yeah say yeah yeah say
yeah yeah say this is the hair staple
that a lot of you probably know and use
by now but I'm I'm late to the Train
like I had to take it over to the
destination cuz I totally missed the
train but I see the train now and I
respect it and I get why you took it
this is a chi hair straightener and it's
great it heats up almost immediately
massive or clunky or anything and it
cools down super quickly I want
something that gets hot fast and cold
faster I want my hair straightener like
my lovers you next okay let's get into
home items can you say yeah say yeah
yeah say this is a candle it's from a
company called homesick and it is in the
scent New Jersey maybe you've seen
homesick I feel like I started seeing
them when I was Christmas shopping at
the end of the year and now I see it
everywhere they basically make all kinds
of candles that represent different
areas countries cities and the sensor
supposedly tailored to what that
location or thing smells like great to
give as gifts it's a soy wax candle if
that means anything or matters to you I
guess so it's like dairy-free candle
there's some of the notes are candy
apple cranberry beach seaside cotton
candy vanilla and musk this is not what
I had experience New Jersey to smell
like but it's fun to trick other people
into thinking that this is what New
Jersey smells like this size candle I
think is about twenty or thirty dollars
and then they make smaller ones that are
like ten or so a typical burn time for
something like this they say is between
60 and 80 hours they really miss an
opportunity to make it smell like a
dumpster fire but I appreciate the
optimism of New Jersey smelling like
cranberries and ocean air cute
hang up say yes say yes say yeah this is
called counter culture probiotic
cleaning tonic air and fabric refresh a
spray scent that you can use to refresh
your furniture your rooms in your house
your shoes if you stanky have a dog
that's also stinky because she is owned
by a stanky and so I needed something to
try and counteract her stank in my house
this has been fantastic it's in the
scent geranium it's not super pungent it
doesn't smell like chemicals it smells
nice and light also I've been noticing
that my shoes stink I use this in the
shoes and they stank a lot less now cute
next these can't be say you'll see these
are said stank shoes is there some boots
from Zara that might have been in my
last favorites video but if not here
they are I've been living in these truly
living in them to the point that they
developed a very peculiar and specific
stay they were like 40 bucks or
something I got little patent leather
shoe tips and the rest is just this kind
of like finally fabric so they're easy
to clean if I ever thought to do that I
can't deal with laces I'm just becoming
that person I can just slide these on up
the next step is orthopedic shoes I'm
gonna wear these until they're worn out
just like my lovers this is a new pillow
and it's a puffy pillow you guys know
that I love Buffy they're actually
sponsoring today's video I have all
their comforters but you're so amazing I
have their sheets and now I just got
their pillows oh my life is complete all
the products are made from eucalyptus
fibers super smooth so it's like just so
much nicer than cotton it makes you feel
like you're on a drug that makes you
want to touch and rub things so that's
cute and legal they're not just software
they're also like more earth friendly
because these fibers are sourced from
renewable forests that take ten times
less water to grow and it's transformed
into the super soft fiber through a
super waste-free production process if
you haven't heard of Buffy I feel sorry
for you but hey you're here now you made
it welcome to this train this train is
pretty packed because they have over
17,000 five-star reviews and their
overall average rating is 4.5 then me
from the Russian judge just pretty good
you guys are interested in trying me the
Buffy products which I highly recommend
I got a hook up for you but also to put
you at ease Buffy offers a free trial
they offer you free shipping and free
returns it's available every single day
but you can try the products in your bed
with your head with your hands and if
you don't like it you can return it for
free so if you want to try you can get
$20 off your order by clicking the link
in my description and using the promo
code great free trial free shipping free
returns $20 off link in the description
offer code gray cute and yeah say yeah
yeah say yeah yeah say yeah this is I
cam you've probably heard about this
I've been using this like crazy because
I thought Elliot was sick and I didn't
want to get sick and so we got some
Zicam Zicam it's a cold remedy that
shortens your cold I don't know the
science medicine behind it it's one of
these little tubes that look suspicious
but you snap it off it's a nasal swab so
look at this
it's a q-tip covered in goop already and
you basically reverse blow your nose you
take all the goop that's in this tube
and you put it into your nose look at
this I mean this is not oddly satisfying
thank you for telling me that this is
not odd ly satisfying to do or watch but
it's helpful and listen maybe I just
have a affinity for things that do that
I've been avoiding being sick knock on
wood
for a while now and just using these a
few times a day and I highly recommend
them if you like putting things up you
know it's legal things up your nose try
some psycho okay that's it for my
favorites video a very massive giant
exciting favorites video I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did give it a
thumbs up leave some comments down below
what are you enjoying this month
I love favorites videos because I like
learning about other products and I
wouldn't necessarily know about before
so hopefully that's how you feel about
this also if you're interested in the
Buffy stuff again link in the bio code
grace you get it now I have to go put
all of these things away or I can just
go do other things need ice cream and
use my mind to ignore the
responsibilities of putting all this
away that's what Jedi's do I don't know
say yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah
this is our last item because you got to
save the best for last this oh dear God
this is Kroger's deluxe churned lactose
free peanut butter fudge swirl it's ice
cream
it's lactose free it tastes king
delicious can't believe that there's
still some left in here elliot bought
this the other day I don't know we're
from probably a drug dealer because this
feels like drugs look at the monster has
just been eating out of this like a
crazy person who eat ice cream like that
me I love low-calorie ice cream because
I'm a basic [ __ ] and I tried to do
dairy-free as much as possible this is
lactose free it's also no sugar added
and it's reduced fat 56% less fat than
similar ice cream so I thought this was
gonna taste like chalk and I'd be like
you know really working my brain it
convinced myself that it's the ice cream
and oh my god this is so good it's like
they made this just for me to light in
every bite yeah you're right you're
right
this is like my brain it's dense it
means well it's a real great time paired
with weed and married at first sight